autre sujet abordé hier soir le projet
alimentaire territoriales l'idée est de
soutenir des maraîchers ou producteurs
locaux et structures et des circuits
courts sur le territoire exemple concret
sur le site d in war al arich
hélène chapelet pour l'instant c'est une
parcelle en friche mais prochainement
ses douze mille mètres carrés de terre
vont se transformer en vergers et des
poiriers des pommiers des cerisiers vont
notamment être plantés ici à l'automne
prochain pour alimenter le territoire
une idée qui a germé dans l'esprit de
clément et qui va devenir réalité grâce
à l'aide de tours métropole ces terres
appartiennent en effet à l'institution
qui a décidé de les louer à
l'association la belle et la bête
pour nous l'objectif c'est de recréer de
la vie ici de produire la nourriture
pour le marché proximité et puis c'est
donc on regarde ce site est bien on a
envie en fait de l'ouvrir aux autres et
que ce soit un lieu de convivialité un
lieu
d'animations d'ateliers aussi ses terres
proches de la loire est délaissé jusqu'à
présent clément n'est pas le seul à
vouloir les valoriser juste en face de
son futur verger on retrouve yolain un
maraîcher de 31 ans il a été le premier
à s'installer sur le site 7 d inward al
arich
chaque année ils payent un fermage à
tour métropole pour occuper les lieux
un espace qui a bien changé depuis son
arrivée en 2018
ici on avait 250 tonnes de déchets qui
s'étaient accumulées on avait la misère
humaine aussi tout autour
c'était une zone voilà qui était pas pas
évidente à gérer
et au fur à mesure donc les personnes
ont pu être relogés et ce terrain étant
disponible donc gelé occupé donc on a
nettoyé on a réhabilité rester dit les
équipes de la métropole ont créé des
conteneurs qui permettent de s'installer
même quand ya pas de bâtiment de hangars
en dur donc voilà il ya tout en
maintenant il ya vraiment un protocole
d'installation qui est assez rodés à la
métropole et qui va nous permettre
d'aller plus vite pour installer les les
prochains maraîchers entre guillemets
métropolitain même si ce sont des
maraîchers aussi indépendant que les
autres finalement dans leur mode de
fonctionnement après depuis 2012 la
métropole à faciliter l'installation de
six maraîchers sur des terrains lui
appartenant
tous fonctionnent en circuit court et
vendre leurs produits en local une
démarche écologique qui évite aux
denrées de parcourir de nombreux
kilomètres et économique car moins il ya
d'intermédiaires plus le prix est juste